foreign
Jan how is it going over there
well
um I have some school debt and some
credit card debt and just looking for
some advice on how to restructure our
lives so we can get out of this debt wow
well the fact that you're willing to
talk like that means you guys are ready
for a change
absolutely sounds like you've had your
I've had it moment
yes and you definitely had it
um I came to a realization with the
school debt I'm actually going to be
expand to leave school and look for a
job just so that we can get out of debt
how far are you in your schooling
um so I have been about a year uh close
to a year and a half into schooling
um I was going to go to law school and
then realize I don't think I want to
practice and so it doesn't really make
sense for me to continue with a degree
um so that costs a pretty penny of
course so this is your year and a half
into law school
of course yeah okay so how much student
loan debt and how much credit card debt
um so total we have about 108
000 in student loan debt and then credit
card debt we have about six thousand
dollars okay and when you say we is that
your your spouse me and my spouse
correct okay
and what's your income household
right now um we just have one income and
it's about 115 000.
and then you're you're gonna leave
school soon what are you gonna do after
that
I'm not sure I'm just looking for for
something maybe administrative work
um I'm just trying to find something
because I'm realizing that this debt has
turned into kind of a snowball and
um we're definitely not looking to to
take on more debt and so
um what is your undergrad what's your
undergrad degree in
um political science
okay
and do you do you feel like you have you
want to stay completely away from law in
any capacity right now or are you still
kind of open to maybe paralegal work or
something in the field
I'm open to work in the field just you
know because
I don't really have too much of a choice
at this point
um but it would be nice to kind of pivot
if that's possible but I mean I've
worked in the field for for some time I
was a legal assistant uh prior to school
so I could always go back to that
I just I don't want you to wait until
you're debt free to do something you
love
and so that's what we're trying to get
you plugged into while you become debt
free and if you can do that and get paid
well and actually enjoy doing it it's
going to make this whole experience a
whole lot better well you'll probably
make more money doing something that
you're passionate about like I think
right now it feels really overwhelming
and you feel kind of you know a lot of
of guilt around leaving this degree and
you know maybe some shame but you still
have a lot of value and I it just
because you're leaving law school does
not mean you can't have a successful
career doing something completely
different and get paid really well doing
it
yeah that's actually pretty encouraging
because I was thinking that I kind of
just had to take anything to to help us
get out of this debt because it's it's a
lot and school loans are pretty tough
yeah it's it's overwhelming right now it
feels like you are staring at a mountain
and it's easy to just want to start
running as fast as possible which we do
want you to run as fast as possible and
be gazelle intense but we want you to do
it with the best strategy with a career
that you love that you're going to be
one of you you're going to want to be
fired up to get up every morning and go
to work and take on an overtime job and
you know anytime the boss says we need
somebody to work late tonight that
you're going to go hey me hey me you
know and get a bonus for doing that like
the more you're feeling passionate about
what you're doing the more you're going
to show up you know and want to go above
and beyond which often translates into
more income
yeah and and that's a really good point
that you make
um there's nothing worse than being
miserable at a job and then also trying
to pay off debt
um and
another issue too is like we have really
high rent because we've lived here in
the city
um and so it's close to 3 500 a month so
when I'm thinking about restructuring
we're wondering if it would be better to
just like move to the suburbs or
um that's that's a tough one there too
it makes it harder for us to pay down
the debt well is he is he working in the
city
yes okay so it would be a little bit
more of a commute so there's a trade-off
there we don't want him driving two
hours each way to work so is there a
trade-off where you could lower your
rent to two thousand dollars a month
live a little further outside of the
city and still have them have a
reasonable commute
yes I think that would be possible
that's something that we're looking into
and I think that would probably make the
most sense for us
um because yeah like what we're
obviously exceeding our income in debt
what size like what size apartment are
you running right now
right now we're in a two bedroom
I mean I know it would be a little bit
of a squeeze there's also just weighing
that you know do you want to live
further out or do you want to go down to
a one bedroom or maybe even a studio for
a season like if living close to the
city is a big priority there's also kind
of going a little bit smaller do you
guys have kids
um right now we don't and we're thinking
about it but yeah okay yeah I think
either way you go whether you live a
little bit further you know get a little
bit of a smaller spot or maybe even rent
out the other room
um getting that 35 it's got a big
compromise either way so it's you
deciding on but is he on board is he on
fire like you are to make some changes
um absolutely
um I'm the one that's kind of driving it
and he's on board with it so awesome hey
for a lot of people that's half the best
you're just getting their spouse on
board so that's great well I wanna I
wanna leave you with some resources Jan
so that you feel equipped and one of
those is Ken Coleman our Ramsay
personality and colleague he's got an
assessment called the get clear career
assessment because I think right now
you're kind of at this Crossroads you've
lost a little bit of hope uh that your
dreams are shattered and we want to tell
you that there is hope for you that you
can do work that you love and this
assessment is going to take you about 15
or 20 minutes and it's going to spit out
some amazing results that very clearly
show you where your passions your
talents your mission lie and give you
career options of things you can look
into
that sounds great and I also want to get
you a copy of paycheck to purpose that's
Ken's book and it's going to help you
you know go from you know just looking
for a job that's going to pay off these
student loans to also defining a job
that gives you purpose that you're
excited about like we talked about
earlier that gets you fired up so it's
kind of The Best of Both Worlds
absolutely and let's pile on Financial
Peace University have you guys been
through that as a couple
we have not been through it as a couple
oh you're gonna love it yeah you're
gonna love that so it's nine lessons I
want you to watch all of them together
you can also join a local class that is
the best way to do it because getting
around other people who are on the same
Journey as you there's nothing like it
uh with that we're going to throw an
every dollar premium to help you guys
get a plan for your money every single
month make decisions and uh you're the
boss of the budget until you make the
budget and the budget becomes the boss
of you and that is going to give you
such freedom because now it's not a
fight it's no no we decided we're gonna
spend this much on food and that's why
we're not eating out and so you guys got
this you have a great income it's going
to go up you're going to come back and
do a debt free scream and I cannot wait
for that day so hang on the line
Austin's going to pick up and give you
from paycheck to purpose the get clear
career assessment Financial based
University and every dollar premium
Austin you've got some work to do man
good luck with that but we love doing it
congrats we are cheering you guys on
this is the Ramsay show